son gohan exploding onto the scene with
the beginning of Dragon Ball Z telling a
courageous and inspirational
coming-of-age story from unassuming and
shy to courageous and heroic from would
be attempted main character to utter
modern-day obscurity the story of son
gohan
is one of monumental highs and
heartbreaking lows with many in the
communities still upset decades later
with how his character was handled and
continues to be handled today so a while
back I put up a poll on my Twitter
asking the question who was the most
disappointing character in Dragonball
leaving options like jaren piccolo and
majin buu alongside go home and despite
Durin's character direction at this time
being a meme for how terrible it was
Gohan still managed to make it a close
race racking up more votes than the
similarly mishandled piccolo and a vapid
caricature majin buu combined so today I
want to take an in-depth look at Gohan's
character to find out what worked and
why it worked and to finally figure out
what went wrong to cause this fall from
grace all in an attempt to answer the
age-old question is it too late for Son
Gohan
[Music]
right out the gate on Gohan's first big
outing akira toriyama demonstrated to us
everything we needed to know about Gohan
as a character he was polite but shy and
when Raddatz arrives Gohan is seen
grabbing tightly onto coke whose leg
further communicating that he is very
much prone to fear as most children are
Golan was made to look unremarkable and
that's important because in a show like
dragon ball where fighters need to be
confident and one to fight you would
think that Gohan seems like a terrible
fit but in reality from a writing
perspective
Gohan size fear and reluctance to fight
were his biggest strengths in making him
a compelling and fun character to watch
when Akira Toriyama added a certain
extra ingredient to his character an
explosive temper it might seem like a
rather rudimentary concept but it's
actually more sophisticated than you
might think
you see everything from Gohan's design
as a character to his sensibilities as a
person served to exponentially increase
the effectiveness of these instances
where he loses control in other words
the most fun that's had with Gohan
occurs when he is made to feel scared
and small when pitted up against someone
who is very evil and large
[Music]
right off the bat from a visual
standpoint it's made abundantly clear
that this isn't a fair fight and so
there's a very clear power dynamic
established in this instance not only is
Gohan much smaller than his foe but he's
also only a young child and the more
helpless and small a character looks
compared to their foe the more shocking
and satisfying it is when that small
character ultimately takes down that
larger individual speaking on the topic
of reactive characters km Weiland said
this is probably the most important
thing to understand about the reactive
protagonist his reactivity is almost
solely the result of the fact that he is
not the one who is controlling the
conflict the antagonistic force is
firmly in control at this point stuff is
happening to the protagonist
and he can stop it in other words for
Gohan's angry moments to achieve their
desired effect
Gohan can never be the one to pick the
fight he must be provoked because if he
picks that fight he becomes a bully and
so right and Gohan as a shy kind and
passive character creates every
opportunity to avoid being a bully the
more scared Gohan is the more courageous
he seems when he overcomes that fear for
the right reasons and this was a formula
that Akira Toriyama used to great effect
when writing for Gohan through various
arcs typically speaking active
characters are usually the most
interesting and compelling characters to
watch because they are the characters
that drive the story forward through
their own choices and actions when an
active character is on screen you pay
attention because this is the person
that moves the story forward this style
of character works particularly well for
protagonists and so reactive characters
as the name implies reacts to the plot
as it unfolds Gohan is a reactive
character but one that was designed to
take full advantage of that fact
reacting to those that pick a fight for
despicable reasons and during these
specific instances is more interesting
and fun to watch than many of the other
active characters in the story the cell
saga was where Goins character underwent
a fundamental change one that reconciled
much of Goines characters baggage and
saw to the climax of his character arc K
M violent when speaking on characters
undergoing change says particularly if
your protagonist is following a change
arc he's also going to be struggling to
understand a lot of his own motives
at this point in the story he's in the
grip of the lie and his blindness about
himself just as much as as any other
factor is causing him to get smacked
around during this part of the story in
other words right before Gohan
ultimately becomes the person he was
always supposed to be he held on to this
belief that he wasn't good enough and
struggled to come to grips with his
feelings on the justification of killing
someone this was something he needed to
be pushed to the point of snapping in
order to act on in the past however now
having reconciled this live with the
truth that it is okay to do everything
in your power to protect the earth Gohan
has changed on a fundamental level from
who he was at the beginning of this arc
to someone who now assumes the
responsibility as Earth's defender the
climax to the cell saga was in many
respects like the ending - Gohan story
or at least the ending to the main one
he was telling up until that point one
that was celebrated by fans and critics
alike and the trouble with that is where
do you go from here it isn't immediately
clear so in a sense it's as if Akira
Toriyama tasked himself with writing a
sequel to a celebrated movie a sequel to
one of the most satisfying character
journeys in anime and it didn't work
this is modern-day Gohan and this is the
goal one that everyone who voted in that
poll at the beginning of the video were
thinking of when they saw his name on
the list when introduced to the story in
early Dragon Ball Z's go on as I said it
was designed to look and act as though
he was and remarkable to subvert
expectations and to complement the
dynamic he brought to every major
confrontation he was in but this Gohan
the one we have today he is unremarkable
contributing little more to the series
than simple recreations of classic great
scenes and moments from his origin story
simple hey remember this type moments
lacking intention and consequences he's
become quite literally a nostalgia act a
similar brand of character fatigue has
plagued other series favorites like
piccolo although in different ways
having played an important role in
dragon ball from his unveiling piccolo
was and in many ways persists in being a
fan favorite despite their truly being
nothing to celebrate with regards his
character anymore Dragon Ball super also
saw to the rise of the character that
took first place in her poll at the
beginning of this video as being the
most disappointing character in Dragon
Ball and while I can appreciate why
people have a great distaste for the
intro caricature that is during the gray
I can't say he's more disappointing than
Gohan disappointment is a result of
expectations not being met and I can say
I expected as much from Geryon as I did
for the future of this guy so what went
wrong in day's end you won the first of
many official guidebooks released after
the series had concluded featured to
popularity polls taken during the course
of the series each ranking the five most
popular characters of that given time
the first of these polls appeared in
Weekly Shonen Jump from 1993 issue 12
towards the end of the cell games
featuring the chapter were cells
self-destructs it lists Gohan in first
place followed by Goku trunks Vegeta and
piccolo the second of the two popularity
polls appears in Weekly Shonen Jump 1995
issue five and six near the end of the
Buu arc featuring chapter 501 where a go
tanks absorbed Buu continues to beat up
on Gohan in first place
sees Goku followed by Vegeta trunks go
tanks and piccolo Gohan is not even on
the list but what makes this more
interesting is that between these two
polls after the seven-year time skip on
the coffer of chapter 421 presents a
message for Master Roshi save Dragon
Ball will continue for just a tad longer
from now on taking the place of the late
Goku as the main character will be the
serious-minded
Son Gohan clearly this arc did not end
with Gohan being the main character and
the only comment made about this by
Akira Toriyama came from an interview
conducted after the series had concluded
he says I intended to put Gohan into the
lead role it didn't work out
I felt that compared to Goku he was
ultimately not suited for the part so I
didn't the character work out well if I
was to read into this and again this is
my own speculation Akira Toriyama up
until this point in Dragon Ball had been
writing it with Goku the active
protagonist active protagonists as I've
said before have a built-in charisma of
sorts and most importantly a compelling
formula because they drive the story
they make things happen go on on the
other hand is a reactive character
meaning he reacts to the story as it
happens to him more than he drives the
plot what's interesting
this is that most characters in movies
and TV shows tend to start their hero's
journey as passive or reactionary
characters and as the story progresses
the protagonist shifts into a more
active role with agency over the plot
this describes the arc Gahan found
himself on from the Saiyan saga to the
cell saga beginning he was quite
literally dragged away to answer the
call to action pushed into situations
but slowly he developed agency and as
his story progressed he shifted into an
active character in the most spectacular
of ways in a video discussing Dragon
Ball G super eyepatch Wolff pointed out
quite accurately that the simple and
general theme of Dragon Ball is
progression through struggle and as you
might have noticed the buuck wastes no
time in establishing that Gohan has
slacked off and gotten weaker he has
regressed for the first time in his life
accomplishing little in the arc apart
from getting his energy stolen putting
up a decent fight against Devorah which
he was criticized harshly during being
beaten up by Buu all before the eventual
power up he receives which comes through
again no struggle from Gohan it's handed
to him on a silver platter the theme of
Dragon Ball progression through struggle
was reinforced with Goku's character who
constantly strove for this ideal but in
switching out the character for Gohan a
large disconnect was made demonically as
the character had an entirely new set of
ideals that didn't complement with what
the show was up until that point and to
compound this problem what made this all
the more striking was that Gohan up
until this point had embodied this ideal
both physically and figuratively
throughout his journey however now as a
happy adult
he has no struggle the anger dynamic
that enhanced his reactive character is
now gone and the size difference that
was once between himself and his foes
while still there isn't nearly as
striking or effective as it once was so
in many ways a lot of the aspects of the
early Gohan character we all loved were
not present in the Buu sagas iteration
of the character so in order for Gohan
to work as the new protagonist Dragon
Balls direction and themes needed to
change in a noticeable way to
accommodate this new Gohan and as seen
during the beginning of this new arc
it's clear Toriyama was trying something
different with the story a slice-of-life
tale about go on getting used to being
part of the society he's trying to
protect
however being around the other classic
characters like piccolo and Vegeta who
still upheld the ideals of classic
Dragonball only reinforced this sense
that something was missing leaving
myself as a writer looking back at the
Buu saga as a whole wondering why did we
spend so much time with Gohan in school
why did we spend so much time with
Fidel's character if she didn't play a
role in the greater plot Gohan unlocking
his power again seemed unearned an
arbitrary and ultimately serve no
purpose for the story except to waste
time another poll I took on my Twitter
asking which of the Dragon Ball Z arcs
was their least favored and fat idli
reflects that these thoughts I have are
not unique to me in Robert MCI's books
story he writes the truly passive
protagonist is a regrettably common
mistake a story cannot be told about a
protagonist who doesn't want anything
who cannot make decisions whose actions
affect no change at any level now to be
clear the jury is still out on whether
or not this arc is disjointed because of
Gohan losing popularity and thus
changing the course of the Buu saga or
if he lost popularity because he didn't
do anything substantial in the arc and
to be clear the Buu saga did absolutely
have some incredible moments and
additions to the story that have lasted
the test of time but all that aside it
begs the question is it possible to
bring Gohan back well yes and no in my
video Goku the misunderstood character I
briefly mentioned how the Gohan
characters story was absolutely over and
how it ended at Cell and I stand by that
that version of Gohan isn't coming back
and it shouldn't but is there a way to
make Goines modern character a fan
favorite again absolutely and this is
how I would do it go on is a reactionary
character and so something I'd like from
him in the future is a story centered
around the philosophy if you have the
potential or power to make the world
better than you should I am of course
basing this story structure off a
particular film and character I'm sure
you are all aware of with a similar
philosophy that with great power comes
great responsibility
I think Goines character can take a few
leaves from spider-man 2 it's a sequel
to an ongoing story and features a
reactionary protagonist and a fantastic
video by Patrick H Williams describes
this aspect of Peter Parker story in
spider-man 2 perfectly if the first
spider-man movie is about Peter Parker
that with great power comes great
responsibility and spider-man 2 is about
exploring that responsibility and the
consequences of it it's about the toll
that being a superhero takes on the rest
of his life for the whole movie
Peter faces consequence after
consequence for being spider-man and
trying to do the right thing now imagine
if instead of the story that isn't being
told about Gohan right now
he was instead struggling to come to
terms with having to manage this
responsibility he has and the sacrifices
he needs to make to uphold those ideals
progression through struggle he's
already flamboyant has an alter ego and
a strong sense of duty which was hinted
at towards the beginning of the Buu saga
I sometimes wonder if this was the
original direction Akira Toriyama had in
mind for the character but unfortunately
we don't know and we may never know in
preparation for this video I went back
through my collection of manga routing
various exerts and passages from Gohan's
story and truthfully it saddens me to
see a character that was once so
inspirational and likable fall further
and further into the background so much
so that today they aren't present at all
in the latest material and as some of
you out there probably have noticed he's
not in the thumbnail of this video
either and the reason the thumbnail of
this video features this Gohan and not
his older counterpart is because this is
the Gohan people love and remember and
unfortunately the other has been
forgotten thanks for watching
[Music]